most modern depictions of women in media
patronize them I mean how does it feel
for you as a female woman of color that
also happens to be an immigrant I
imagine that it doesn't Empower you or
make you feel particularly good either
the treatment based on my color based on
my status as an immigrant it's as if
it's a handicap it doesn't make me feel
empowered it makes me feel discouraged
cultural milia is the rise of narcissism
especially amongst women the perspective
has become seesawing between I'm
incredible and then going on the other
side which narcissists do all the time
is that if anything is wrong in my life
the fault lies with someone else and
their desire to bring me down if we
continue to patronize women we're going
to create a culture of people that
refuse to change refuse to grow and most
importantly refuse to negotiate with
anybody the perspective that they're
trying to sell is like no no no no if
you said it you were right all along
they just want to keep you down that's
you digging your own grave